[Music]
after watching this video you should be
prepared to explain why the human
tendency to daydream can be interrupted
using a storytelling marketing approach
to list three key benefits of
storytelling when it comes to consumer
engagement to realize that different
consumers are looking for different
relationships with your company and to
explain the difference between
storytelling and story sharing let's
begin lesson 1 why storytelling is
essential in social marketing when we
think about the way that our company or
our brand or our organization is
represented to the world it's easy for
us to be focusing on things like quality
and credibility and whether or not
someone wants to buy from us but it's
also important to understand that for a
lot of consumers the very idea of who
you are it's also important it's not
always just enough for people to know
the name of your company or product
they're interested in understanding what
the story is behind your brand and that
might be something like how you came to
be or why you exist or what your mission
is or it might be something about the
personality and sort of the lifestyle
that's represented by your individual
company now the storytelling movement
has been an area that we've really seen
a lot of growth and a lot of
improvements in the last several years
in social media with more and more
brands moving towards this idea of sort
of humanizing their companies by telling
the stories that come out of the company
itself out of the use of the product or
even out of the consumer stories that
you know share how products benefit
their lives or again just what goes on
in that interaction and that dynamic
between the organization and between the
customer side of things now when it
comes to storytelling there's several
different ways in which this approach
offers value to a business and one of
the key ones is on the emotional side
we've talked a lot in the social sharing
dynamic in some of the other areas of
you know the spread and the viral
concept about how emotion is one of the
most powerful things that impact
people's decision-making and engagement
with the brand so when it comes to
creating that emotional connection or
leaving people with some type of
emotional response storytelling is one
of the most powerful ways to impact that
it gives you an opportunity to sway the
emotion of consumers in terms of how
they look at or view or are receptive to
your brand now another thing that
storytelling can really do that adds a
lot of value is the idea of making you
credible because a lot of times the way
we tell stories especially when we're
incorporating in true to life examples
or you know consumer stories there's an
implied credibility that comes through
that storytelling and come through those
third-party experiences that can help
people feel more secure about doing
business with you not just more
emotionally positive but actually feel
that security of trusting that what they
think they're going to get or what
they're hoping to get that there's going
to be enough follow-through and enough
other people have had a positive
experience for them to really trust that
that's what's going to happen now
another area that storytelling brings a
lot of value into a company is the in
the idea of making you memorable because
human beings are wired for stories we
are much more capable of recalling broad
ideas and concepts and emotions when
they're communicated via a story so if
we give someone a list of facts a list
of selling point
a list of reasons why to do business
with you the ones that touch them
emotionally they were that you know
problem solved those tend to stick with
them but a lot of the data gets lost but
when we put it in the format of the
story and someone is sharing what their
experience was our brains literally
archive it and categorize it differently
and our recall level goes up so again
along with building trust and along with
creating that that emotional impact the
fact that people are better able to
recall the information that's
communicated to them via that story
helps make it a very powerful marketing
tool now in addition to that it's
important to keep in mind that on
average people tend to be day dreamers
in fact study after study shows that if
our minds aren't occupied with an
important task if we're not truly
focused on something we tend to drift
off and when we look at that concept of
daydreaming the average human spends
literally half
their waking hours day dreaming we
average 2,000 waking drifts per day with
an average length of about 14 seconds so
you do the math on that mm times times
14 seconds that's a pretty good portion
of our day where our brain is drifting
off but when they look at the brain's
ability to stay focused versus having
those drifts we stay focused during a
story if we're reading a book if we're
watching a movie if someone is telling
us an engaging story we are better
equipped and better able to put those
drifts off and really stay focused on
what's happening so that's one of the
other sort of scientific and concrete
reasons why that memorable factor comes
into play when we present things via
stories now stories also allow us to
connect in one of the easiest ways
possible again because our brain is
going to be a little more focused on
being able to receive that message so by
using stories to spread your brand
message or to explain your offerings or
to demonstrate how they were you
increase the chance of keeping your
audience focused on you and giving them
enough recall that they can come back at
a later point to actually do some
business with you now think of
storytelling from sort of a mindset of
how we meet and engage with other people
so in general when we're meeting up with
a prospective friend or a job prospect
they were coming for an interview of
service workers even just a stranger on
the street any conversation that goes
past just hello how are you doing and
the cursory you know kind of polite
responses it tends to be a story this is
what we do when we meet were naturally
wired to seek out insight and common
ground and information about who another
person is and in those interpersonal
relationships the types of questions we
ask you know the words we use they're
indicative of the type of relationship
we want to build so clearly if you know
if you're single and you see someone
else that you know you hope might be
single that might be one of the early
questions you ask and then based on
whether you know there's a romantic
interest there you're probably going to
ask different questions than if it's a
interview prospect for a job or if
you're meeting up with a you know
co-worker for the first time the
relationship that we're
looking for denotes the type of
information we want and that's one of
the important things for us to keep in
mind when it comes to storytelling
because we also have the ability to
tailor our story to the audience so we
can put those different features upfront
we can weave them in in a different way
if we're appealing to a group of 60
something females that love to sew
versus a group of 20-something
Millennials that love whiskey tasting
it's a different message that gets put
together with different focuses and
teachers there's also different things
that we're going to put forward if we're
proposing you know a million dollar
contract versus a twenty five dollar
impulse buy that someone can you know
click and order online and have
delivered the next day now on the
business side of this we need to think
about what the story that we need is
because a lot of times we get so focused
and business on getting the conversion
that we forget that sometimes part of
getting that conversion is creating
those emotions building that credibility
and Trust you know helping them have
exposure to what's possible and for a
long time this has been done through
education we might put up videos or
articles that aim to educate and to
demonstrate the story side of it brings
that more social interaction and
environment into the mix and that's
something important for us to keep in
mind so a quote that I really love about
this concept that sort of lays the
foundation of why it's so important
comes from the chief content officer
over at digitize and he says the
challenge is clear by now intrusive
interruptive self-centered marketing no
longer works the way at once did and its
effectiveness will only continue to
diminish in the social age because again
the way that we share information back
and forth with each other and the ways
that that messages spread it happens
differently in the social media age than
it did before when it was more
advertising focused and where marketing
really was more about you pushing the
advertise pushing the message and sort
of the Don Draper style of you know if
you don't like the conversation change
the conversation and tell people what
you want them to hear because so much
marketing is now driven by consumers
through that conversation we need to be
able to approach it in a different way
now another side of
that is the idea there's a difference
between storytelling and story sharing
and some of it boils down to semantics
but some of it also does need to be kind
of taken into account when we look at
how we might put our message together
because semantically consider the
difference between telling and sharing
so to tell is to communicate information
facts or news to someone and spoken or
written word its to order instruct or
advise someone to do something that
second part that I want you to keep in
mind but to share is to give a portion
of something to another to tell someone
about something especially something
personal it's a again it's a slight
semantic difference but it's a huge
difference in terms of our approach and
I love this Seth Godin quote that really
pairs up with that idea the best part of
Show and Tell has never been the telling
part it's been the showing letting
someone see an experience and inviting
them into that shared experience and
that's one of those things that makes
the social version of storytelling
really more like story sharing
especially if you want to do it in a way
that creates that back-and-forth
consumer engagement story telling in its
traditional sense is more the stories
that we've put into commercials and
advertising and there's a place for that
there's a place to put that together in
the social realm and it's very important
but the other area that that we're just
starting to kind of merge into and it
really needs some exploration by brands
is that idea of the social sharing where
it really is about engaging back and
forth with your audience and inviting
them to be part of an experience with
you and with your brand so ask yourself
do you want to tell your story to people
or do you want to share it with them and
let them share their story with you and
how do you meld those two together and
what does that look like within your
particular company or among your target
audience so now that we've laid the
foundation of why storytelling is so
important and sort of what type of
impact it can have the next thing we
need to do is look at the business side
of telling your story what does it look
like to create a narrative or something
that's representative of either your
business's story or sort of the
lifestyle or concept or ideas that you
want to
promote to people now there's tons of
questions you could ask yourself to
start building your story but we can
focus in on a couple key areas as a
starting point to build from one of the
first ones is the idea of whether or not
you have a founder story now for a lot
of brands the story of their founder is
so interesting or inspiring that it
catches the eye and it makes people take
a second look at the product so think of
the companies that are sort of iconic in
terms of who their their founder or
their leader is so whether that was
Steve Jobs in the role he played at
Apple or Walt Disney and the inspiration
and the role he brought to you know the
entire Disney complex or loads and loads
of other businesses there are lots of
examples out there of how the brand
itself was so tied to the person who was
sort of leading the helm that that
became part of their story and people
were really interested in it now we can
find loads of examples of different
brands where the founder really plays a
critical role in representing who they
are now great example of this is Spanx
the founder Sara Blakely has really
embraced the story both of how she came
up with the idea which was basically she
was trying to fit into a pair of cream
pants for a party and they didn't fit
quite right and she knew that when she
put her pantyhose on everything seemed
to lay nicer so she literally cut the
feet out of the pair of pantyhose and
put them on and that's what launched the
brand if she loves to sort of tell that
story but she also loves to tell the
story you know from her tagline of
putting her own butt on the line pays
off because the way that she made her
first sale to Neiman Marcus is that she
literally dragged the buyer into a
dressing room and she went in and she
put on a pair of white pants and came
out and said you know here's what I look
like without them and went back in and
put her pair of Spanx on under the white
pants and came back out and said now
here's what happens what I'm wearing me
is and the buyer from Neiman Marcus
ended up placing a huge order and it was
the first major sale that she got that
put her in place somewhere so those
stories and sort of the yeah this is how
it happened you know this is literally
what a difference
makes that becomes part of the brand and
the sort of Sarah Blakely's journey is
an entrepreneur and you know moving her
way up into the you know the Forbes list
of you know highest earning females in
the United States all of that plays a
huge role in how they promote the brand
itself and in sort of the storyline and
the lifestyle line that they want to
promote to the people that might buy the
product
now on a completely differently themed
vein we have fast food chain Wendy's in
the US and Canada where Dave Thomas was
the founder and even though he's you
know passed away several years ago he's
still a critical part of the brand and
of the story because basically it was
the idea that a working-class guy makes
good and continues to act like a
working-class guy while building a
massive charity because it wasn't
uncommon even when he was CEO to see him
show up in a store somewhere and start
working behind the counter or sweeping
the floor somewhere he always played
that role that made it clear to his
employees that he wasn't above them that
he was one of them and part of them
and has a huge huge ongoing charity
effort for adoption because he was
adopted as a child and so all of that
plays into the narrative of Wendy's and
who they are and what their brand
message is and and the lifestyle that
they want to promote to customers in
fact if you if you go there now and you
buy a meal and you get your cup all of
the cups have stories of kids when they
were finally adopted and what it meant
to them when they were adopted or you
know what their first experience was
having a new family so again that plays
into the story just because people are
interested in the start of where how it
came to be so looking at you know what
the stories are from within your team
and it doesn't always have to be that
founder story sometimes it's just
someone who works there post cereal
paired up with burns group and use real
factory workers to create a round of
honey bunches of oats commercials and
let's let's take a quick look at what
one of those actually look like so you
can kind of see the storytelling in
action here I get out of working and I
go to the store and somebody smell
around mmm smell cookies that's all know
you just mailed me I just got out of
work that honey buns Oh as well as no
even nothing now they're short simple
easy stories there's nothing complex to
them they more just make you smile and
laugh but they're the types of stories
that come from listening to the people
who work at your company from thinking
about how your company and their
experience impacts the world around them
now another question that we can look at
is does your company or group solve a
problem now this isn't about the reasons
you think you're great for the reasons
you think people should buy from you
it's about that unique way that you
solve an issue that consumers or on the
b2b side of things you know the buying
agent is looking at that they're trying
to fix now great example of this is
Airbnb or you could look at uber or lyft
on a similar vein allowing people to
experience travel in a new and
affordable way but also letting you to
owners or drivers earn extra money you
know from something that might have been
sitting there empty anyways you know
that idea that when you're traveling you
don't have to stay in a bland expensive
hotel in fact when I travel for business
pretty much any place I go I always book
via Airbnb because you know if I can
have a bedroom and a living room and a
kitchen especially for traveling as a
family and there can be you know
separate bedrooms as opposed to having
my kids all stay in the same room with
my husband and I it just makes sense but
there's also the story side of that of
its different experiences and that's one
of the big things that people talk about
is how the experience changes and even
on the side of trying to recruit people
to put their properties it becomes about
the freedom and the lifestyle that's
enabled and there's tons of examples on
YouTube of people sharing how you know
leasing out that you know their vacation
property the rest of the year when
they're not there you pays for the
vacation property and more or you know
the people who now travel full-time
because they're able to lease out into
their apartment or their home or
something else on Airbnb this story side
comes from the problems that are solved
for people now another great example of
a company that focuses on their story
from that side is Dollar Shave Club they
basically took a problem everyone
complains about and they made it go away
you know the idea that razors cost a
ridiculous amount of money that you
always forget to buy new ones until it's
too late through shaving with a dull
blazer and it's just inconvenient so all
of their messaging focuses in on that
idea of we make it cheap we make it easy
and you know it
shows up right at your house and you
don't ever have to think about it
anymore and their commercials all tell
the same story with kind of a you know
funny modern millennial focused way so
let's take a look at one of those as an
example as a founder of my own Club I
let them know how does yours work Dollar
Shave Club presents what the fact it's
simple it shows from one of our three
great razors we'll give you a free
reusable handle in each month we'll send
you replacement cartridges for just a
few bucks that means you get to share
with a fresh blood anytime you want
which feels amazing well I'd be locked
into a contract no we wouldn't lock you
into anything
that's a relief how long for delivery
I've got a conjugal visit next week well
what if I don't have to shave that often
no problem after you sign up you can
choose to get replacement cartridges
every other month you sound like my mom
I like that oh what's this I hear about
Dollar Shave Club selling more than just
razors you heard right we make all our
own high-quality grooming products like
dr. cover shave butter boogies hair gel
and big cloud daily face moisturizer
with sunscreen now you know what the
fact is up with Dollar Shave Club so
join the club today
[Music]
Hey once you become an expert in digital
marketing then subscribe to the simple
learn Channel and click here to watch
more such videos turn up and get
certified in digital marketing click
here